hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report you know we talked from time to
time about the casino Gulick about the
trend in technology and government to
enslave the global population behind
devices and to be consigned to a life of
clicking on ads for Scooby Snacks and
the second you stop clicking on those
ads you die and you get deep platformed
and off the grid and the Jeff Bezos
sends in a drone to carry away your
ashes well there's more on that news
story Stacy
well max you were around on the internet
and in fact an internet entrepreneur
during the first dot-com boom remember
back in the 90s you also went and you
saw John Perry Barlow author of the
Declaration of Independence for
cyberspace and back in those days the
notion that the government or any
corporation could stop this explosion of
freedom and free expression and the
libertarian ideals of the early internet
would have been laughed at but now we
have allowed essentially just two or
three corporations to pretty much
control the entire online experience and
lo and behold we have this headline from
Bloomberg internet consolidation opened
the door to censorship Titans like
Facebook Google and Apple defeat the
purpose of a decentralized web the
British government released proposals
this week to hold online and social
media platforms responsible for harmful
content a few decades ago we might have
scoffed at anyone who even thought they
could regulate what people say on the
Internet
no longer today the centralization of
platforms and services providers makes
enforcement surprisingly easy it's just
a matter of picking which layer of the
tech stack to hold accountable well you
know evolution survival of the fittest
relies on mutations and mutations come
about through spontaneous
combustion if you will or spontaneity
accidents collisions klar and this is
what makes us human now online
censorship censoring the platform the
primary platform in which we communicate
means the end of evolution
it means the extinction of humans as we
know them and the beginning of this
casino gulag era where our humanity has
been destroyed but for our only purpose
is to click on it so yes it does seem
like the matrix in a lot of ways we are
the batteries that power a few
corporations revenue model and the
hackers of the internet era of the 90s
and the entrepreneurs at that at the
time they were very optimistic and
idealistic about the ways that the
internet would foster free speech and
communication the biggest enemy of
course came from within you see that in
Bitcoin as well
the biggest enemy was comes from within
that the hackers get frustrated that
they're not like a Craig Wright for
example he suffers from Bitcoin
derangement syndrome and it attacks the
very medium upon which without which he
would no one would ever have heard of
him even though he's a fraud so this is
tragic but predictable so well you could
compare it to hear what they say the
British government is going to ban
censor get Twitter get Facebook force
them to deep lat form people who speak
words that are harmful we don't know
what harmful means whatever is harmful
to the British government obviously they
believe what Julian Assange said was
harmful to the American government by
releasing videos of the assassination of
a Reuters journalists in cold blood
right in the middle of Iraq covering
that war so do we need to know that's
information what is going to be bought
from us I think the other thing Julian
Assange of course was what was on that
cyberpunk mailing list so he was there
very young at the time on the cyberpunk
mailing list from which things like
Bitcoin
or burst the other thing about this is
that they underestimated the majority of
the population you know the majority of
population is happy for Facebook to
moderate everything and keep harmful
content from them if they're a
Republican they don't want to see
anything from AOC in their feed and
anybody who writes anything about AOC
they want them blocked and banned and
this is harmful or MMT they don't want
to hear that the same with Democrats
they that let's start shrieking and
shouting at the skies if if they see
anything about Trump and they'll want
those people put in a gulag or
imprisoned and that's and that's not an
exaggeration because they do want to see
Julian Assange face the death penalty
for releasing those emails which prove
that Hillary Clinton and the DNC anyway
were conspiring to rig the the primaries
against Bernie Sanders so they
underestimated the ability that people
in their little echo chambers to become
basically you know totalitarian and
their desires right so we now know that
from the images from the Ecuadorian
Embassy that the United Kingdom
government tortures journalists we can
say that without any equivocation and we
also know that their involvement with
HSBC and the money laundering in Mexico
resulted in 60,000 deaths and many
murders of journalists
thank you UK government well you're so
free and beautiful I could just bug you
let's turn to the United States where we
allegedly have free speech but you know
a lot of our media is very liberal you
know we do have like the right-wing you
know online radio and AM channels on
radio but in Fox News and the right-wing
but majority of the rest of the cable
news and news is more liberal and yet
because they've lost their minds you've
talked about Bitcoin derangement
syndrome they this is like free speech
or well democracy derangement syndrome
the the people voted the wrong way and
they can't they just can't mentally deal
with it they have
two and a half years later lost her mind
but if lawmakers want to prevent the
dissemination of certain content on
social media they can cover most of the
u.s. population with a phone call to
Facebook and Twitter
that's all it requires two corporate
entities if governments want more
comprehensive coverage they can hit up a
handful of cloud providers that serve up
over half the Internet problematic
websites effectively vanish if deleted
from Google which handles 90% of search
activity and apps can be rendered
unfindable if Apple and Google simply
remove them from the app stores so free
speech you know it's an interesting idea
here when the US which is a leader in
speech and the Constitution and freedom
they can attack speech at the ISP level
was what we're saying and these are
private corporations government
restricting your freedom conceivably
they could do the same for Bitcoin you
can attack Bitcoin at the ISP level and
but then that opens up the game theory
of the greatest free speech invention
ever
that would be Bitcoin for other
countries my belief is that if the US or
the UK wants to go down the path of a
suicide they want to commit suicide and
many animals and creatures in the nature
are suicidal and so the as it collective
the US or the UK could commit suicide
you know that's not outside the realm of
and look it breaks it was obvious
attempted suicide so another country
however will pick up the mantle and say
okay well we'll pick up the Bitcoin
mantel and we'll promote free speech and
that is such a huge competitive
advantage that's why in the next 50
years and you see this happening China
and Russia and others they're buying
gold and they believe once they make the
switchover to Bitcoin it's us goodbye
it's United Kingdom adios and we'll see
a new player on the world stage
people could scoff at that and look at
if they look at the world stage but the
fact is somewhere like Uruguay had one
of the most repressive regimes on earth
just 2530 years ago and now it's one of
the freest places on earth so things can
change radically and rapidly now in
terms of this D platforming and this
whole sort of farmville click akan and
there was a viral video last week I
don't know if you maybe heard of it but
Instagram influenced their cries at
prospect of nine-to-five job after
account shutdown so this woman young
woman Jessie Taylor had racked up over
130,000 followers when her Instagram
account was removed and it was removed
because trolls just like probably from
4chan just like targeted her site and
kept on saying it was spam or there was
on there was questionable content
inappropriate content so Instagram the
algorithm just shuts you down indie
platforms you but she like released a
three-minute clip and she was shrieking
and freaking out that basically because
she was no longer allowed to be an
influencer on Instagram because they had
cut off her source of income that her
only option then would be a nine-to-five
job or a homeless prostitute so this is
this is like the global economy nowadays
this is our new totalitarian reality
you're either an influencer which I
still don't quite understand what it is
that you get people to like and retweet
and therefore companies will pay you
money to retweet something and now the
only other option is either working at
McDonald's what she talks about or
becoming a homeless prostitute well okay
if you go to the dog track you know they
have the rabbit and the rabbit goes
around the track and the dogs chased the
rabbit okay that's an influencer an
influencer is the rabbit and you never
catch the rabbit but the dogs running
around so she has to move now from being
the rabbit to the dog she's got to be in
the dog she's got to be chasing other
rabbits and of course in a it's a pretty
brutal world out there after a couple of
months as a professional dog racer they
put you down because it's brutal or it
you could become then become like well
it gets worse from there I won't yeah
look at some of her quotes because it's
quite interesting and I think it's
telling and reveals a lot about the
mentality of the generation the
millennial generation and the one below
them Generation Z which I which she is
in and just what the sort of stress
these people are confronting because in
China you have the social credit score
this is similar that you can only exist
she said quote I'm nothing literally I'm
nothing
without my following I am nothing
without my following she repeats what
some of you guys have to realize is I
have no skills I'm twenty freakin
thousand dollars in debt from college so
I can't even go back to college if I
wanted to because she can't afford to
continue her education so this is like
you're nothing without a following mmm
they reminds me of that Tom Petty son
I'm free free fallin you know he's just
like open the pod bay doors Hal and let
us fall out of this rocket ship because
we're heading to earth that you know
breakneck speed and like Lori Loughlin
we may find ourselves having to actually
get a job well it also reminds me of
another song I'll counter that with
another song Janis Joplin freedom's just
another word for nothing left to lose so
these people like our we've created a
situation where we have these two just
two entities or three entities Instagram
is owned by Facebook that they could
just shut you off from the world and so
you always have something to lose you
know we can just all join hands and sing
Kumbaya we're all you know loving people
and we can enjoy our transitional period
well when we watch the deuce for example
and it's set in from 1971 up until 1978
so far in New York City and that was
before this grid before you were reliant
on this for your social interactions and
meaning in life so there is there was a
freedom not everything was better in
life but it certainly was there was a
freedom where you could just walk away
and do anything you could be a schmuck
and and continue to live you can't be a
schmuck anymore and you can't you know
it's easy for you to just be you have so
much to lose
Oh much more Frank Sinatra coming away
after the break welcome back to Kaiser
report I'm max Kaiser time now to return
to our conversation with Dominick
frisbee over there in the UK in London I
believe Dominic welcome back
thanks very much max yep London that's
right all righty
Dominic Stacey tells me that you wanted
to sell me on the idea or the situation
there and breaks it you know I talk a
lot about it on Twitter certainly so
what is your thoughts there well I can
certainly sell you on the idea of brexit
I can't sell you on the current
situation because the current situation
is a total mess we voted to leave the
European Union nearly three years ago I
mean that's a phenomenal amount of time
and we're still there and because it's
been so long since the vote and because
Teresa may the Prime Minister's majority
is so thin more and more and and her
leadership has been so weak and without
vision more and more dissidents has been
able to fester and grow the the ox'
dissidents has been given oxygen and so
we've seen the remains side of the
argument get stronger and more like
after the vote pretty much everyone most
politicians and most people on the
remain side were like oh we had a vote
we lost the vote fair enough we are need
to one of the referendum result let's go
but because we haven't left the remains
side has got more and more vocal and
this dissidents has grown to the extent
that now almost without any shame
whatsoever the various institutions that
run this country from the House of
Commons to the great media outlets and
every everywhere else are in this huge
conspiracy basically to stop brexit by
whatever means possible so we've seen
all these constitutional these things go
on in Parliament which are without
constitutional precedent and the speaker
a guy called John Burke oh he runs the
basically is in charge of the house of
parliament he just it's like whichever
whatever whim he fancies on a particular
day he'll let a vote happen or he won't
let it happen and he
so biased against the leave side of
things and they're trying to stop brexit
in every way possible but without
actually saying we're stopping brexit
they can't be that honest about it so oh
we need to get it delayed or the deal
isn't right
oh and know we said we'd leave without a
deal but no we can't leave without a
deal and all we need to get Parliament's
approval before we can actually leave
all these various things and with every
delay the dissonance grows and now it
looks like it's now been delayed till
October till Halloween another nine
months and you know the chances of our
leaving actually leaving if the
referendum result actually being honored
get smaller with each passing day so I
certainly can't sell you the situation
well right but I can but I can sell you
brexit and brexit like the one chance
that an ordinary person has to stand up
to great institutions the authorities
the banks all the things that run a
country is the ballot box that's the one
thing you know he doesn't have the
platform of television to stand up and
say his mind the one thing he's got is
the ballot box and he said what he said
in the ballot box in June 2016 and what
he said basically was we want to go we
want out of here and the people spoke
and it was a tremendous democratic
moment here finally was a referendum
that you could vote in where what you
said actually had an impact and that was
a tremendously empowering thing it
showed democracy in action and the fact
that that vote has been honored it just
shows how bent and corrupt the whole
system really is has become wasn't a
detriment when the breaks of Tears for
example when they were pitching brexit
to the country did it did it turn out to
be a negative that they their basis for
leaving was based on a pack of lies for
example the the idea that this 300
million pounds for the NHS etc all they
all these fundamentals were worse or do
you have to be fraudulent that promise
to the NHS has already happened like we
haven't even left the European Union yet
and the funny
the money to give extra 350 million to
the NHS has already been found now I'm
not defending that statistic because I
don't I'm a less spending on the NHS
kind of guy not of more spending on the
NHS guy but that money has already been
found the lies were told on the remain
side of the argument it was an election
so both sides told lies you know truth
stretching promises that all happens in
election is normal but the lies got told
by project fear every single projection
by you know we were told that every home
was going to lose four thousand three
hundred pounds we're all going to lose
our jobs
not if we leave if we just vote to lead
and it's going to be a house price crash
there's going to be a stock market
collapse we're not going to get any Mars
bars there's going to be no more fish
and chips there's gonna be no these are
at one point they was projected that
there'd be an outbreak of super
gonorrhea I mean it was just lie after
lie
so please the I hear the repeats like
was lying not true was the remain sided
with the biggest liars
so austerity is finished in the UK then
they're all the money is flowing again
to all the various programs as you
mention apparently NHS is getting
funding against austerity is finished
it's over and they've moved on to a new
thing I never really bought the
austerity narrative in the first place
max but there I mean the government cut
thousands of cops they defunded then HS
they cut many programs homelessness goes
up child mortality goes up I mean the
country's looking you know its deprived
of cash it's it's being choked to death
not quite right government spending
actually rose over the period they said
there was austerity but government
spending rose well to bail out banks
sure but as far as the money going to
Christmas so let's say the UK was in the
Premier League at one point they were
part of the EU and benefiting gloriously
as being part of the Premier League they
were a pretty good team they're saying
we don't want to be Manchester United
anymore we don't want to be Chelsea we
want to be Sheffield Wednesday we want
to be in the third tier we want to play
in the WTO rules we want to be part of
an emerging market why would you
voluntarily leave the top trading bloc
in the world to enter into the
fringes of the global economy well I
don't agree that that was what happened
we just want to become a self-governing
free trading nation with accountable
leaders the the problem with appear why
supporting the European Union it's like
it's growth is anemic Germany's in
recession there's no accountability in
its leadership it's not democratically
accountable it's led to mass
unemployment across the whole of
southern Europe how can you support an
institution that does that I can support
in the UK and what I see the UK
government doing to its own citizens is
atrocious it's deplorable its anti human
rights it's disgusting it's pathetic and
when you have people there's no
Constitution
there's no rights there's no free speech
rights you know I tried to do journalism
in the UK and was hounded by Ofcom
that's not a free speech country they
make the EU look like a glorious Citadel
on a hill comparatively yeah Britain is
a trash dump
well I'll defend our nation against that
outrageous slander and I agree that the
press isn't is not nearly as free as it
should be but we got rid of by voted to
leave the EU we should get rid of a
major layer of bureaucratic and there's
plenty of more bureaucratic to still be
got rid of I agree but we got rid of a
big chunk of it by voting to leave the
EU but you haven't left it in you and
you're never gonna leave it because
because you don't have politicians that
are working into anybody's interest but
the supernatural state of various global
bureaucrats and you do a terrible job at
doing it let me explain something if you
truly do we need to vote against them or
do we vote for them you leave are you
going to disinvest all of the European
pension funds they're currently owned
all the UK's transportation
infrastructure it's all owned by every
time the a British person uses the
underground or some other transport
they're giving money to some retiree in
Germany on a beach somewhere in Turkey
right are you going to disinvest all the
effect the EU and
institutions owned the UK right now are
you gonna disinvest you're gonna say oh
we just want to be not a 2.5 trillion
pound economy we'd like to be maybe the
same size as Greece they have more
independence so is that what you're
aiming for yeah
no max and European companies are not
the same as the European Union that's
the European stage European state owns
the European it owns UK transportation
infrastructure they state welfare system
owns your infrastructure max if they
want to sell it they could sell it every
single day you sold the town by the mill
asking me to defend public private
initiatives because I'm not that's not
what I believe it I'm just saying that
the the two are Wed at the hip there in
their in their separable you can't just
take 60,000 pages of regulations that
have been built up over decades and
decide over some absurdly inappropriate
vote and put out like David Cameron to
walk away from the eve number one yeah
what why I always thought that Max
Keiser was a champion of the little guy
he was a champion against the tyranny of
the institution the tyranny of the
corporation the tyranny of unaccountable
bureaucratic elites I thought you were a
champion I didn't realize you're a
champion of them I thought you were
planning on exactly and it's a little
guy benefits by having a civilizing
influences of the EU versus the
kleptocracy in a monarchy and the
aristocrats of the UK they are the most
damaging hellacious slanderous garbage
mouth idiots of any government in the
world that's who I'm trying to protect
the average British citizen the EU gives
them some civilizing influence what do
you take the EU out it's going to be
like Lord of the Flies it's just going
to be a rat eat rat that Island is
despicable let it just sink well uh if
it's a shame we're not in the same room
because I'd currently take my socks off
and shove them in your mouth so I could
get a word in talk you got a minute
if if we left the EU and we and the the
Democratic vote was acted on properly
then we would prove
to be a proper democracy that honors the
votes of its people and it's a great
opportunity to rebuild our nation a
fresh beginning a free trading country
Britain has always been at its best when
it's been a free trading independent
nation and we could go back to being
some semblance of that at the moment
we're just a little vassal of the EU and
I don't think any right minded British
person likes the role of being a vassal
well I tell you one upside to being
separate from the EU and the rules of
the EU would be you could increase your
money-laundering capacity in the City of
London by a thousand percent and and how
the city launder money to commit fraud
the best the place for Lehman Brothers
AIG and every other financial scandal
goes right through the city of London
that's what you're good at if you take
the EU regulations away you'll it be
even better as a tax haven and money
laundering service for the global
autocrats and kleptocrats so I'll give
you that oh my gosh we're out of time
Dominic thanks so much for being on the
Kaiser report thanks for letting me get
a word in max alright and that's gonna
do it for this edition of the Kaiser
report with me max Kaiser Nastasya would
like to thank our guest Dominic frisbee
he's the author of Bitcoin the future of
money if you want to reach us on twitter
it's Kaiser report until next time bye
y'all
[Music]